ils sont venus nombreux ce samedi au
marché de Montigny-le-Bretonneux une
quinzaine de bénévoles du Secours
populaire des Yvelines et du mouvement
d'enfants copains du monde se sont
réunis pour une collecte de fonds
bonjour monsieur collègue de fonds pour
l'urgence séisme en Turquie en Syrie
merci beaucoup après le séisme qui a
frappé le sud de la Turquie et la Syrie
l'association veut contribuer à l'effort
collectif 100.000 euros de fond
d'urgence ont déjà été débloqués par le
Secours populaire français mon sexe ça
va durer des mois voire des années la
situation et donc du coup on fait valoir
le travail de notre réseau euro
méditerranéen pour nous permettre
d'accompagner les personnes dans la
reconstruction que ce soit de leur vie
de leur habitat et de tous les espaces
publics qui ont été dégradés
pour la Turquie
merci beaucoup bonne journée ça m'a
beaucoup ému de me dire que c'est des
gens comme nous enfin surtout beaucoup
de voir que j'avais mon ami qui était
dans ce pays enfin dans un pays à côté
et te dire que bah genre ça aurait pu
être nous et c'est enfin ils ont notre
âge ils sont comme nous et eux ils ont
un homme séisme avec autant de moi mais
en général dès que je peux plutôt sur
une collecte et faire des dons
régulièrement pour pour aider finalement
un peu tout le monde et que ça soit
utilisé au à bon escient je pense que
tout le monde a besoin d'un petit coup
de pouce à un moment donné donc c'est
toujours bien de de donner de sa poche
quand on peut il me dit que les
catastrophes naturelles c'est quand même
très compliqué à anticiper donc les
personnes n'ont pas eu de chance que ça
tombait sur elle quoi donc pouvoir aider
comme ça c'est c'est bien je trouve au
total 1071 euros ont été récoltés
d'autres actions sont organisées partout
dans le département la ville de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye a par exemple voté
une aide exceptionnelle de 10000 euros
en faveur des populations sinistrées